health officials say the key to slowing
the spread of covid is for people to
know when they have the virus of course
that's why clark county
will soon be stepping up their mobile
testing efforts joe mohler spoke to the
emergency manager about
what exactly is planned and he joins us
now live joe
yeah well the easier it is to get tested
the more likely people are
will be able to do it and that's the
idea that clark county officials have
now they want to step up their testing
efforts
here in the area i just came over here
and this day last day here
despite not showing symptoms sharon
jones says she wanted to get tested for
copenhagen
she said she was in and out in no time
at the cheyenne high school mobile
location
they got a lot of testing places so
there's no excuse
as cases go up clark county is looking
to make testing easier the cheyenne high
school site was part of the strikeforce
testing program
soon they will increase the amount of
tests being done we want to double what
we're doing now the weather is by hours
or by day
clark county emergency manager billy
samuel says they are going to make
testing sites like the one at cheyenne
high school friday more common
rate as everyone knows for 100 000 has
been climbing
and we need to make sure that we try to
stop the spread by people know that they
they test positive they can at least
start isolation and quarantine in
themselves
so we're not we're not spreading it and
that's our main goal
right now dates are planned through the
beginning of next month next is
doolittle community center tuesday
november 17th
it's good because a lot of people are
getting it and dying
so it's more or less i feel like be safe
than sorry
and samuel says they are working on
additional locations through
next month and if hours do change the
hours we did list
a few moments ago will remain the same
but they'll just be extended
reporting live joe mohler 8 news now